welcome back to glamour and filtered the
interview franchise we get to the heart
of some of the issues that mean the most
to some of the world's most inspiring
celebrities and today we are joined by
the singing sensation who's just nailing
the chance right now is Kim Petra you
were classes the youngest ever
transgender person and now you come on
250 million streams across Spotify
across all streaming sorry what have you
learned about yourself through the down
times and how have you got yourself out
of them I think just in general just
like doing what you love it's really
important and you know not giving up on
yourself I've definitely been close to
giving up and to you know feeling like
this is never gonna happen and you know
I've been doing this since I was like 12
like I've been writing songs since I was
like 12 and posting like videos on the
internet of me singing and writing songs
for other people and all of that stuff
and it really like it didn't happen
right away but I just like kept at it
what's that sound believe come from I've
always just kind of wanted to do the
same thing but I feel like pop stars did
for me when I was a kid like I remember
just like hating school and not having
any friends and like being bullied
pretty badly and kind of running home
from school and watching like when
Stefani loved angel music baby like
music videos and like just kind of
escaping my like reality through like
pop videos so you just touched on the
fact that you had schoolyard bullies how
did that make you fail you know just
being transgender and being going to
school is tough what has bullying taught
you about your power as a human people
will not like your people will like you
that's just like a reality of life and
it's and it's fine and you cannot please
everybody and a lot of people like bully
people because they jealous or because
they have like their own personal issue
that they like project on you and
sometimes it's that it doesn't even have
to do with you sometimes people are just
bored how would you describe gender to
you now what does it mean to you that
I dare to meet personally just like it
doesn't mean anything what matters to me
is like if you're like a good person or
if you're talented or if you work hard
or if you're a nice or if you're a
generous or like human qualities like I
don't necessarily think being a girl or
being a boy or being gay or being
straight like says anything about a
person but I do feel like for right now
we need these boxes to like raise
awareness about like issues like being
transgender I just hope that like one
day it's like not as big a deal as it is
right now when I was researching you yes
today I came across this interview to
them this morning where you were called
the world's youngest trans sexual person
yeah and it's like wow like now we
wouldn't even use that type of phrasing
it was right back there and I mean that
was like 10 years ago so it's definitely
like changed so much from like ten years
ago I mean there's always got to be like
a title I guess for anything but it's
kind of just get rid of it I oh yeah
that's enough yeah but to a lot of
people that's like such a like alien
like crazy concept and yeah I don't know
wait for the world to change in your
situation right
yeah wake up to what the possibilities
are transgender person are right it was
really frustrating it was just like a
lot um just about that like and now it's
it's cool to be like known for my music
like I'm not going for it being
transgender I don't got my music we're
just sick I really think like as much as
like we talked about how like social
media has like all these negative
effects and it does and some things
about it really suck and comparing
yourself sucks and you should never
compare yourself to anybody or anyways
Instagram it's not real but at the same
time now you you don't have to do things
like any particular way you can just
like make your own life your own career
your own following you can build it all
yourself what do you think is the most
pressing thing facing the transgender
community today given the world that
we're living in well I just think
ignorant just just uneducated people who
don't know anything about it and just
don't want people to get educated about
it and I think be
educated about it as like such an easy
thing like just like lookup like
transgender person interview done like I
think you know then you know what's up
it's like a five-minute thing you can
just do one time and then you know about
it and you're like okay I guess I know
about it like maybe I'll have a
transgender kid one day or something I
ever know oh yeah totally you don't know
what surprised you the most about being
transgender artist why I'm an
independent is because I went to major
labels and all they would talk about is
just like my gender people were either
leg yeah hided or or like use it and I'd
kind of didn't want to do either and I
just like kind of wanted my music to
speak for itself
no it's just like I'm just gonna like do
it myself and like perform at every gig
up there is a leg builder legit fan base
you could sit there with all these music
bosses who said to you hide the fact
you're transgender person what would you
want to say to them I feel like I'm
really like proving myself by working
really hard and by like quality of music
and I don't have anything to say like at
the end of the day that's kind of what
I'm doing it's just proving people wrong
how has music helped you with your
mental health would you say I think a
lot I think I get over a lot of stuff by
writing about it and I feel like when I
write a song I really get to like sit
down and focus I'm like exactly the way
I want to say it so it's super like
therapeutic when you say that music is
like for a PTA yeah what is music helped
you deal with the most probably
heartbreak I probably just like look
writing about heartbreak it's just like
I constantly do it so I feel like it's
really helped me over that what you tell
yourself in those light moments when
you're dealing with them in Breaux life
I feel like sometimes I just like dig
myself into being really depressed and
like thinking everything is pointless
and usually like the next day everything
is fine I've done this a million times
and every time it's okay in the end what
kind of relationship do you have with
yourself pretty um so I've learned to
embrace it but also I've learned to just
like take it easy and like be proud of
myself yes in like moments of like
success or when I'm doing something
right like I've you know you have to
like celebrate and
you happy along the way because if
you're not then what's the point if
someone's listening to this right now
who's going through the things that you
went through when you were younger and
were bullied or being bullied and just
in that sense alone that's such a
debilitating thing to have to deal with
being bullied people this online or in
real life what advice would you want to
give them
I guess the coolest thing I could say
it's just like the coolest people that I
hang out with now but I look up to were
like kids that were bullied in school
and just like weren't not popular at all
and we're not cool at all in school
those are all the artists I'm inspired
by those are all the best friends that I
have those are like literally all the
coolest people I know so you're probably
really cool what's incredible about you
as well as you turned negativity into a
massive positivity pop tracks and you
should be damn proud of yourself thanks
for being out here living your truth and
doing it go you baby so much
for more inspiring videos with such
inspiring people such as Kim Petrus make
sure you subscribe to the glamour UK
channels now and we will see you in two
weeks for another edition of glamour and
filtered
[Music]